oh my god i love it oh i love it and i
love you guys and anne specifically and
all of you and you rainbow infused space
unicorn and you beautiful sassy
mannequin come to life and you
opalescent tree shark leslie you are the
master of the metaphor i recently
compared her to a nutrient-rich chia
seed ann there is nothing harder in the
entire world than saying no to your
beautiful face but i'm going to no ann's
my doctor
and she's the most beautiful nurse in
the world you're ann perkins sperm that
is worthy of your perfect eggs does not
grow on trees and you beautiful tropical
fish you're smart as a whip and you're
cool under pressure you've resuscitated
a human heart in your bare hands no i
haven't you haven't no you will you're
that good of a nurse you know that i
fully support any woman's decision
especially a beautiful unicorn nurse
like yourself in creating the family
that she wants but you are so brilliant
and kind and stupid hot i mean you're
definitely going to find a wonderful guy
who loves you and respects you and fills
your home with multi-ethnic genius
babies van you poetic noble land mermaid
you're right once again
thank you
fun and you're a genius your brain is
almost as perfect as your face oh and
you tricky minx yeah oh ann perkins
you perfect sunflower
and you're beautiful and you're
organized oh yeah you're too beautiful
to be funny it's not your fault you've
never had to compensate for anything the
rest of you ugly nerds need to give me
some joke stats oh and you beautiful
rule-breaking moth alex gives my
campaign legal advice and ann is the
greatest human being ever invented
man you beautiful spinster
i will find you love
what did you say something love you
oh and you beautiful naive sophisticated
newborn baby what oh and i always forget
because you're so pretty you're not used
to rejection and you're such a good
friend you're a beautiful talented
brilliant powerful musk ox thank you ox
for keeping this ship afloat sweet and
beautiful anne has never been dumped
before but i'll tell you he'll never
lasso another heifer is fine as you
annie oakley it is the most beautiful
object i've ever seen it is like the
anne perkins of dresses yay
nobody can fill your shoes anne with
your tiny little doll feet nobody can
match your ethnic hybrid energy
everybody brings their own unique
strengths to the table some that even i
don't have you shut your mouth you have
all the strengths instead of getting
swept up in my boyfriend's personalities
i'm dating myself and trying new things
so every time i go out to eat i order
one thing that's typical me and then
something that i would never order now i
have two best friends ann and ann each
one more beautiful than the other okay
we have a 100 bid for ann perkins 200
200 thank you so much 200 for the
smartest most accomplished woman i know
and check out that bond can i get three
300
yikes you look weird so do you
that's a lie you always look beautiful
and you tricky bastard
well well well
you coy bastard
oh ann
you're so sweet and innocent and pretty
beautiful ann
thank you for coming to get me
and you devious bastard
oh good ann you're so beautiful
beautiful anne i beg of you will you
just shut your beautiful pie hole
just sit there let me stare at you
while you silently support me on this
game plan slash
your quiet support means the world to me
as well as your tacit endorsement of all
my behaviors oh he's so beautiful flynn
you're so beautiful i mean you're always
beautiful but right now you are the most
beautiful glowing sun goddess ever well
as a wise woman once said to me and you
cunning pliable chestnut-haired sunfish
phase 26 is the key to my plan good
memory sunfish
you